iPhone maker planned 700 million dollar
plant in India to shift away from China
this is a Bloomberg story Apple Inc
partner Foxconn Technology Group plans
to invest 700 million dollars in a new
plant in India to make phones parts and
possibly assemble handsets on a 300 Acre
Site close to
bengala bengala Bengaluru airport
according to Anonymous sources the
investment is one of foxconn's biggest
single outlays in India to date and may
be used to produce some parts for its uh
nascent electric vehicle business the
factory is expected to create a hundred
thousand jobs and marks a shift of
manufacturing away from China and
tensions between U.S and China India has
offered Financial incentives to Apple
suppliers and the move away may help the
country close its Tech Gap with
Chinatown
people need to think about India this
way it's kind of the same shade
India is the Texas of foreign
manufacturing they are trying to attract
a lot away from California which is
China that's what's going on here and
Foxconn so India's government is trying
to do that and Foxconn is hedging a bet
because they see risk in China and they
also get a lot of blowback right now
from the United States on Chinese
manufacturing this is a this I believe
is one of the early shots in what's
going to be an insane War over the next
10 years economically for the
manufacturing center and there's only
one country on Earth that has population
that starts with a B that China fears
and it is India
yep I've been saying that for I agree
with you I've been saying that for a
minute I think India is a uh the country
they go to sleep fearing the most
because India says we don't fear you we
don't give a what you think about
it Adam do you have any thoughts on this
yeah I mean it's it's good to see that
these big manufacturers are moving away
from China and everything they've done
they still are intellectual property uh
I think modi's been in in charge since
what 2014 give or take so he's doing his
thing out there and then uh you know the
only thing cheaper than uh
underage Chinese labor is young Indian
labor I mean you're being wrong I mean
being honest sounds like India is the
new home of cheap child labor I mean
he's being so these companies are not
there because they give two shits they
want to make money yeah so uh it hurts
but you know it's cheaper than Chinese
yeah this isn't the companies coming in
running sweatshops this is the Indian
government giving Financial incentives
for 300 freaking acres and a hundred
thousand jobs that's pretty freaking
meaningful that's amazing that's great
Vinnie give us your Insight from the AI
standpoint from the AI standpoint
robots are going to take over that thing
in 20 years 100
in India oh yeah but speaking of age is
really fast I know we have we have you
know January 6 and all that to talk
about have you been seeing the fake uh
where they're having Biden speak and
it's not Joe Biden and the it's pretty
scary
it's on top of a deep fake it's the
voice if you close your eyes it's so
accurate I'm saying right now in 10
years when they perfect it you're not
gonna know who the hell called you and
told you to come here or give you this
or or or or or you didn't say that or
you said something racist it's going to
be a fake AI saying that you said it
it's going to be almost impossible to
prove that it was you I can't wait to
meet your fake AI oh my God I mean have
you heard on Pat look at them is this
steak are you familiar with the 2011
film We Bought a Zoo the Matt Damon
picture scarjo is in it as well although
her performance isn't anything to shake
a stick at if I'm being honest like it
was directed by Cameron Crowe the fellow
who made Jerry Maguire
show me the money
anyway and so I was watching We Bought a
Zoo
if they perfect that how much better
does that sound then I like being in a
pool with kids and they rub on the leg
and all my like what the that sounds
presidential by the way that could help
him in 2020. 100 percent
oh by the way all he has to do is he has
to like go like this
like can you see my mouth what I'm
saying as long as they can't see my
mouth you'll just be like yes put on a
mask so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here